-Our guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated comedian
for her work
on "Saturday Night Live."
She hosts and executive-produces
"Supermarket Sweep,"
which airs Sunday nights on ABC.
Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend
Leslie Jones!
How are you, Leslie?
-What's up, Seth, baby?!
-Oh! I miss you, Leslie.
It's great to see you,
but I, of course,
wish you were here in person.
How are you feeling this
morning -- or this afternoon?
-I'm great. I'm great.
It's nice and sunny out here.
See all that sun in the back?
-[ Laughs ]
-That's right --
you're an L.A. person now.
Does that mean
you voted in California?
-Why you got to ask me
that on air? Why?
-[ Laughs ]
-Why?
Why you got to ask me that?
You ask the white people that,
Seth?
Oh, yeah.
I'm taking it there early.
-I -- We just have
a few questions
about some discrepancies
with your registration.
Ms. Jones...
[ Both laugh ]
-Were you --
-I think I did some mail-in
[bleep].
-Did you -- Do you enjoy
watching results come in?
Do you like -- Do you like
looking at the maps on CNN?
-Well, I just was telling --
telling your people --
I was like, "It's like waiting
on a STD test."
-[ Laughs ]
-"Do I got it, man?
Do I got it?!"
-But you feel -- You're feeling
like you probably don't have it.
Is that where
we're at right now?
-I'm feeling like the test
is going to come back my way.
-That's good.
-You know?
Do you -- It is so much.
I feel like now it's like
a show for TV.
You know, John King at CNN,
he's turning the maps.
Steve Kornacki over at MSNBC.
-I hate --
I hate them weathermen.
They are weathermen.
-[ Laughs ]
-That's what they are.
And you know what's so upsetting
is watching them
trying to work the monitor,
and then they push
the wrong button.
You'd be like, "Yeah, 'cause
you're trying to be impressive,
and you're not impressive,
okay?!"
Stop with the weatherman stuff.
And then they get
the marker stuff.
It's so annoying.
It's annoying.
You know what I really hate,
Seth?
Seth.
-Yep.
-And I love the Cuomo.
I love me some Cuomo.
-Yeah.
-But when they walk
across that floor --
when they walk across that floor
while they're giving the report
like they're doing something
really, really, really
important,
like they're going to talk to
somebody else across the room --
Seth, I want to run up there.
I want to run up there, Seth.
I hate that part.
-I know what you're talking
about, where they're like,
"Let's go.
We're going to walk over
to John King at the map."
-Oh, it's....
-You don't like
the walk and talk.
-And then the camera does that
swift thing behind their back
like they're --
it makes me want to --
You're not important!
[ Laughter ]
And you're telling me
the same thing you told me
five seconds ago.
-Yeah.
-Okay, he got Michigan.
Okay, he got Michigan.
Okay, he got Michigan!
-So [Chuckling] Leslie,
you -- did you --
-And, Seth, can we get
"American Idol"
to help them get
the results faster?
How "American Idol"
can get their stuff
in one night and you can't?
-What about --
Did you watch --
There was a very strange thing
that happened last night
that, obviously, both candidates
gave speeches late in the night.
Did you watch those?
Were you up for that?
-Yes.
I had to watch the speeches.
Okay, first, Joe Biden comes out
with the speech that we need --
like, be patient,
which is very upsetting again,
America,
that we got to be told
to be patient
on some stuff
we've been doing for years.
You let one person come up here,
an idiot,
and tell us something
about the rules --
something we've been doing
for years --
and then, all of a sudden,
it's something different.
So we got to be tell people
to be patient,
which is so annoying.
Grow up, America.
Grow up.
But even on the other side,
I am like,
"You know, how did
'American Idol' do that?"
Anyway, when Trump came up,
though, I was like --
have you ever just seen a kid
that is just mad
because somebody
don't like them?
Like, he had this little paper
and everything.
He was like, "Yeah, we're gonna
take this to the court.
We're gonna take..."
And I'm just like,
"Oh, get out, please.
Please, just get out."
-He also sort of --
he basically announced
that he had won.
-And he didn't.
-And what do you think
about that play,
with so many states undecided?
-Well, it's just like --
this is what I've been saying
all along, Seth.
This is why I love you
and "Closer Look,"
because you nail it on the head
when --
He's just -- He's just doing
that celebrity thing
with the hands
and the cues and the --
and the repeating himself.
And of course he comes out
and he puts these ideas
in your head.
And if you say it enough,
it's like --
okay, it's like when they want
a hit on the radio,
and they play the hit
like every --
like two times an hour.
And you keep hearing it --
you know you don't
like that song.
You know you don't like
the "Shape of You."
You know you don't
like that song.
Okay.
But it plays three times.
So now I like the
"Shape of You" now.
Now I like the "Shape of You."
Okay?
So that's what Trump does.
Like, "Oh, yeah, it's a fraud.
It's a fraud.
It's a fraud."
So you put that in your head
of people who are not taking
time to think
about the democracy
of this country.
Yeah, he's doing --
he's doing entertainment 101.
That's all Trump is doing.
-I want to ask you
this question.
You and I are both --
we've both been very honored
over the years to get
nominated for an Emmy or two.
-Yeah.
-We haven't won them.
Have you ever thought that
you should have
played it that way
on Emmy night,
and just shown up
at the red carpet
and just started talking about
the fact that you'd won it?
-Well, we already seen
Kanye kind of do it.
You know what I'm saying?
You remember when Kanye
ran up on the stage
and was like,
"no, we won."
[ Laughter ]
Like...
And, you know,
you could probably
get away with that, Seth.
You could probably do that.
But if I ran up onstage
and snatched a statue
from somebody white,
they would beat me like
I had broke into Walmart
and not tried to pay
at the regular register.